hola
quisiera en los próximos minutos
compartirles una historia compartirles
un sueño una utopía
una esperanza una necesidad
méxico es un país extraordinario
no solamente por su historia
por su cultura por sus tradiciones por
su diversidad o por su geografía
méxico es un país extraordinario
principalmente por su gente
su generosidad su gratitud y su
solidaridad son solamente algunos de los
valores que la distinguen lo podemos ver
en muchísimos eventos en eventos de
júbilo como son celebraciones
nacionales juegos olímpicos olimpiadas
cuestiones que tienen que ver con
campeonatos deportivos o fiestas
culturales en donde la sociedad
principalmente de las los jóvenes se
vuelcan y abren sus brazos para recibir
a todos y recibirnos a todos
podemos decir que una de las grandes
frases que encontramos mundialmente
reconocidas y que todos la oímos y que
nos identifica es mi casa es tu casa eso
habla del carácter de un país también
podemos decir que méxico es un país en
donde la solidaridad de su gente se
manifiesta en momentos de dolor de rabia
de frustración de enojo de tristeza como
pueden ser los sismos los huracanes
o la violencia en donde la sociedad
civil se vuelca y principalmente la
sociedad civil compuesta por las y los
jóvenes se vuelcan y rebasan la
capacidad del estado para poder resolver
los problemas que nos duelen o que nos
aquejan es esta sociedad civil la que
nos levanta y nos levanta y nos levanta
y nos reconstruye
también podemos decir sin la menor duda
que méxico es un país muy lastimado muy
agraviado
mueren más de 40 mil jóvenes al año la
mayoría por causas violentas
en méxico la brutal impunidad
agresividad
y violencia hacia la mujer desde que
nace es algo que nos indigna y nos
recuerda todos los días el gran vacío
que tenemos como país
méxico finalmente es un espacio de
grandes contrastes
el mundo el mundo es de grandes
contrastes
si nosotros nada más nos detenemos y nos
imaginamos a los miles o millones de
emigrantes que dejan lo más preciado que
tienen que es su hogar su país su
cultura sus tradiciones y que salen en
búsqueda de un sueño al que muy pocos
llegan nos damos cuenta de estos grandes
contrastes grandes contrastes que por un
lado nos dan esperanza
y por el otro lado nos dan temor
y es aquí en donde tenemos que hacer una
primera reflexión
una primera reflexión en cuanto al papel
de la educación
por un momento pensemos y soñemos cual
sería nuestro ideal en educación qué es
lo que tenemos que hacer o cuáles son
los límites en los cuales nos tenemos
que mover
siempre que nos siempre que pensamos en
educación
generalmente planteamos contenidos
qué es lo que deben de saber cuáles son
las habilidades que deben de aprender
cuáles son las profesiones del futuro
cuáles son las habilidades que tenemos
que incorporar cómo podemos poner las
nuevas tecnologías en uso para los
jóvenes
pero yo quiero decir que aquí tenemos
que hacer un alto total
los espacios universitarios tienen un
papel fundamental en la construcción de
ciudadanía
es ahí donde se conoce y se reconoce un
proyecto de vida es ahí en esos espacios
donde en gran parte se construye el
futuro y el proyecto de un país o de una
nación
los espacios universitarios son estos
lugares en donde cientos miles millones
nos encontramos y nos reencontramos
todos los días son nuestros espacios de
enorme fuerza y vitalidad son esos
espacios en donde se manifiestan todas
las formas de pensar de ver de sentir al
mundo son estos espacios en donde las
clases sociales la religión el origen
las creencias o la diversidad no son sus
obstáculos son su fortaleza
los espacios universitarios son esos
lugares que sin importar nuestra edad o
el tiempo que estemos allí nos gravitan
con su energía nos gravitan con su
fuerza nos gravitan con esta capacidad
que tienen los jóvenes de inconformarse
sin conformarse a la injusticia de
inconformarse a la intolerancia ya la
soberbia
quisiera preguntarnos que nos
preguntáramos por un momento qué es lo
que hacemos con estos jóvenes que llegan
todos los años
realmente entendemos la búsqueda de ella
de ellos y de ellas por encontrar un
mejor país por encontrar un espacio en
donde puedan ellos seguirse construyendo
o solamente nos vamos a quedar detenidos
en su formación profesional y en sus
competencias profesionales
tenemos una disyuntiva y no podemos
equivocarnos el país necesita que nos
sumemos a un proyecto
tenemos que encontrar y reencontrar este
espacio universitario
en donde a través de la argumentación a
través del debate a través de las
humanidades y de las artes podamos
construir nos como sociedad
tenemos que hacer de estos espacios
universitarios ciudades santuario
ciudades en donde los jóvenes se puedan
construir y reconstruir ciudades y
espacios en donde estén seguros y den
seguridad a su ambiente ya su medio
tenemos que encontrar otra vez este
lugar en donde ellos puedan proponer
soluciones e integrarse a un proyecto de
nación cada vez más complejo
déjenme decirles que las competencias
profesionales las hacemos muy bien
nuestros planes y programas están
acreditados el ejercicio profesional
está certificado todos los días estamos
trabajando en esta parte disciplinaria
la otra parte es la que hemos descuidado
la otra parte es la que hemos olvidado
la otra parte es aquella que nos va a
poder permitir volver a soñar con un
mundo mucho más incluyente mucho más
diverso mucho más fuerte los entrenamos
para poder ser capaces de desempeñar un
ejercicio profesional pero no los
enseñamos entender las necesidades de su
país y sumarse a la solución de ellos
les enseñamos a entender ya conocer un
dilema clínico
pero no los enseñamos a defender la
democracia o sus instituciones los
enseñamos a poder ser parte de una
estructura pero no los enseñamos a
indignarse ante la injusticia ante el
medio ambiente o ante la violencia que
nos lastima todos los días ese es el
espacio universitario que tenemos que
rescatar los empoderamos para que sean
exitosos de manera individual sin
enseñarles que finalmente el éxito
colectivo el éxito como sociedad como
grupo nos va a dar mucho más tenemos que
hacer un alto y recuperar los espacios
universitarios
finalmente quisiera compartir con
ustedes algunas reflexiones
tenemos que mostrarnos ante nuestra
comunidad tal y como somos
seguros inseguros con miedos valientes
incluyentes vulnerables
con todas estas características que nos
distinguen
tenemos tenemos que hacer
de la solidaridad de la generosidad y de
la gratitud
estos valores irrenunciables en nuestros
espacios tenemos que tener
a la filosofía a las artes a las
ciencias y las humanidades como estas
herramientas fundamentales para poder
construir nos como sociedad
tenemos tenemos que encontrar este
espacio de convergencia en una sociedad
y en un país y en un mundo que se nos va
entre las manos
tenemos que estar agradecidos de estar
vivos el estar vivos nos vuelve
vulnerables pero nos quita los miedos
para poder soñar y perseguir nuestras
utopías
tenemos que terminar el viaje en el que
hemos estado y atrevernos a un viaje
futuro
que nos ayude a construir un humanismo
crítico muchas gracias
[Aplausos]